hello welcome to you let's play that
literally no one is watching but it's
too damn comfy this game is too damn
nice to ignore I don't know I like the
game and I like playing it so I'm gonna
keep playing it sorry where were we
I don't remember Shh here we are
who's got the best nose you do well not
me that's for sure
oh yes use always talking to yourself in
the mirror you certainly do are we
literally just seeing the nose what are
you looking at
what nanny the f man that's right
Kristen Channel so what did you want to
play it doesn't matter much Billy why
don't you just play your scales and I'll
do that accompaniment for it ha are we
trying to calm you down or me are we
trying to calm you down
what does that mean I happen to find the
simple things mindless and relaxing fair
enough
oh I get it
beautiful gorgeous very nice dare I say
we found the memento oh my god it's so
nice I want to buy the soundtrack for
this game
men she's doing all the work while he
just playing the scales didn't you used
to play the triangle yes and the
triangle is one of the most new ones and
misunderstood instrument there is true
that true that they sure try hard to
play some fancy schemes he really
doesn't like scales this man okay so we
need four more mementos people were very
upset that I didn't like Mentos sorry
people have different opinions okay the
hard surface candy is not my thing
he left something in the piano time is a
place all right now the Mentos what are
your doing slacking off up - you may
have already set up a whole wolf boy
that's chase and I named it Asha spa I
just ride everyone would sit who sits
would pay turn oh I liked I liked I take
care of your allowance and not cold yet
you can't even read I Wes man not sure
I'm gonna go look for her that's why you
need to get your butt down here and help
alright hey another another another we
just need two more fam
the lad the lads grow so young so fast
what
I can't I swear to god I'm a literate
man this place is perfect to play chair
pac-man what don't do that don't do that
not the time once not the time nor the
place
what am I missing here I'm missing one
more maybe talk to him nope oh there it
is with that nanny buddies it's
flickering into another family oh sorry
we need to do we needed two more or not
any idea what that was about how should
I know
well you are the technician and to be
fair you have to have extremely high IQ
to understand windows this is the only
weird thing that happened this trip are
you sure you don't want to forget a wire
mister
how dare you
my calibrations are s putnis as Bambi's
but after he lost his spot okay okay I'm
just saying you should keep a nap all
right
and I open we shall kept shout Sean to
be kept there's a hole in the curtains I
think I know where we need to go through
the hole in the curtains of course yes I
am a genius genius Pierce hey have you
guys seen Sofia
check the practice halls I saw her going
there Thanks
well do y'all should visit by the way
we're gonna miss having her player all
right we will so it's a far well for
Colin with a plane and for a while to
Sofia for performing and they never did
you don't know that
we got a Mentos you've got five Mentos
which means which you know what it means
if you made it this far you know that's
right
if you're a loyal bro
ah it stinks it's partial time can peer
solve this puzzle it must be a tricky
but my god we can't move that direction
we can't move this direction but we
can't move this deadly oh oh it's skips
one oh no I made a huge mistake
don't worry I will solve this very
promptly look at that you got a line
them up you got a line them back us up
ma'am it's what I tell you I told you oh
god I made a mistake
damn it maybe we should get the green
ones right [ __ ] even demian we CP
what the heck
look at that
why am I not getting any points I'm
killing it huh where my bleeding point
say huh
potato patata huh
oh here we go
no it skips that son of AB
there it is where's my hundred percent
Nonnie here we go bum bum bum bum bum
Jania spits strikes again thank you very
much
don't worry don't need to stand up just
a simple like on the video will do and
of course donating to all of my Patriots
oh yeah sorry
I needed to go in say is it me or does
it sound a sound a little bit like sorry
for ruining the music
there's memories of his wife's last
concert yet we didn't see any of her
concert itself there was a flicker of it
back there I guess
still still self-absorption a high
perhaps but it's a pain what we see here
is largely influenced by his actual
regrets interval try to remember that we
were that what we see here has more to
do with relevance than importance to him
something still feels out to me but
alright
see you on the other stand let's go Akim
us everybody
someone commented that I didn't know
Pierce was Japanese yes it's true
I speak fluent she mean it's just
appeared I maybe I should get that to
her
yeah that's faith waiting we have to
kiss a transistor bathing me bikini we
have you seen the view up there it's
unreal giving him an old man's voice
anyway besides you need extremely high
IQ no one no one be around to tell me I
suck at cello I blow that I forgot to
cut out in Episode one where I was
looking up this thing online and is so
embarrassing cuz it is me going for 20
seconds I'm sorry again nobody's perfect
shake it gently hey you get a pass race
you to the top
that is so cute the girl from the
balcony huh
I don't know if his wife would like this
it's not much too fast over there just
they were just kids
and besides you need extremely this was
long before Collins even met Sophia
still the memories we see here tend to
be relevant to his real term regrets
right it's not our job to judge let's
just see how it goes did he have a
childhood love that he never let go of
my god I'm really curious where are they
going with this
so beautiful such a detailed RPG making
game
you gotta appreciate you got I
appreciate it okay just get me a moment
in you and it's a race to the top
it's a cello you try carrying this thing
up here not to mention you're like
weightless hey new idea break time
it's necessary
cello it's a hat it's a Halloween thing
that's actually true
just like my heart what would you
disagree like you see it's [ __ ] I'm
sorry I'm so stupid
my I have Tourette's I swear to God hey
what are you doing
hop off we're gonna roll down the hill
and die when you see great wealthy green
I thought you said I'd wait let's at
least be a little consistent
why are the best places always so hard
to get to what's the point if it just
tires me out to get here there might as
well might as well might as well as just
close my eyes and pretend I'm their king
you need it I feel like I can relate to
Colin you can me I'm Kenny I just wanna
make a play nerdy oh my god it's me and
Marcia you can stay if they win it but
I'm going baby damn interesting all
right we'll follow it's a bit annoying
we have to walk the same path but at
least we don't have to carry a cello am
i right that was a high five it was a
little weak but we'll get it next time
maybe with some teamwork it takes two to
tango
see we need making you pee just askance
start off still but it's been made
Hey not everyone's got those fancy
private tutors like you I'm just
figuring out as I go
hmm where did you pee beating Jimmy okay
but it's just a Scouts you know
oh wow that's really good
we'll it could be ways it could always
be worse
what a great quote don't you practice
yeah but it's so boring to play the
scale over and over I wish I could just
jump directly to playing melodies hey
Jean all right here it goes
see it's cute
with a rate the company meant anything
to be me ready
isn't that what Colin and his wife were
playing in the last memory II can we
judge now c3 kid she's pretty good at
diggity same beliefs you know yeah you
know what you know what's interesting
about this memory there
these early memories of his are way more
vibrant than the more recently a
possibility always but even so perhaps
just early stage not all these earlier
memories I Clary them the reason ones
only show me particular alright because
I'm not sure how I feel about
rewatching the nupoc me neither
interesting we need two more Mentos
das and Chios momenta does peripheral
hmm but what are we missing
we haven't even found them the main man
toe an empty cello case in a weathered
green book we know that green book he
sure likes talking back taking that book
everywhere I'm surprised it's not
getting blown away by the wind cuz it's
not real
oh [ __ ] sorry I thought I already read
that they were talking about the scale
okay so what's the mementos Wow
there's item J and flurries I think it's
he beats kids wow it's the one of their
house it's time for everyone's favorite
time thirty paths of a puzzle you like a
puzzle so I saw the puzzle and what oh I
see this is easy
excuse me look at that
genius Pierce strikes are gone I can't
do it like that shoot shoot
am i right hey you look at that it
solved itself Wow
wah wah whee-wah winger he did it
genius peered strikes many times many
times through the last place and I love
it I love it so much I'm not I'm not as
weird as I I normally am okay don't
judge I'm just trying to play a game huh
have you ever seen while he biscuits
around this part of the world don't know
I'm not the one to be plant analogous
[ __ ] please it's called bone inist oh
hey look over there only two men Mentos
but I am starving oh wait what age is
this is that Archer no it's okay okay
okay
careful up - don't look a bit loose it's
all good date
I'm got this you should come up up here
and play too
lesson add leaves come down and let me
fix it first
never it's a fierce oh I thought you
said look that is for a second oh like
Jesus Oh what is happening what is
happening what is happening what is
happening what is happening excuse me
excuse me is that oh he fell
are you okay shun ash yeah yeah I am a
cat
I am a miserable see you gotta let kids
fall sometimes parents ease day coddling
their kids trying to protect them from
everything okay it's a horrible truth
but there's only so much you can do to
predict your a was that that's right I
am and I I know everything about
parenting that's right thank you
don't know let's try not to jump to
conclusions well we know that we're down
I'm gonna just be there randomly come on
hey to Mentos what's wrong with you
the joy of being a parent probably what
a short memory let's keep up the P BAM
we found it ha ha ha Bala it's time for
everyone's favorite moment Fitz
tradução puzzles it's what I like the
most so I just realize I'm supposed to
get obviously the actual memento what is
happening with my hair today man I have
been just doing all of them so stupid
all right let's go
this game has so much charm the music is
so nice I really really enjoy it so we
jump to another tire
oh we're young man oh we're like a 13
years old maybe sara is that a skunk or
wow that's a pretty shady thing to do Oh
being waiting for me hey what took you
so long
sheesh immediately get a leash
Unni whoa why do you learn to do that
it's Kate Kimmy what you gonna shame me
to ski yeah the classroom should be
clear by now are you gonna stay for our
band practice as well she really is slow
huh ah don't don't they remind you of us
when we were young
no one babe hey sorry I ruined
everything
you're watching the wrong let's play I
told you
this kind of game was just nice to take
in the atmosphere
huh their school looks familiar
smaller but then again I guess many of
the geezers here grew up in the same age
area geezers geezers such a British term
is it do you use that in America maybe
I'm wrong I'm sure everyone's gonna
correct me now that's just where we have
our art class how do you knew these
training URIs no my god throw nap these
are the good ones
I used to love art class it was a is the
first subject I got the highest score on
I was so happy I even hugged my teacher
and he got me the confidence to get the
height is great in everything because
I'm a genius genius peered strikes again
nah I just don't like going in there
there's plenty of other nicer and
quieter places to eat at are you dead
sure I'm not shy I just don't care to
bother
oh so gritty hey I like her I'm not shy
I just don't care about it
sure buddy the wind keeps everybody
sleek there hey can you actually work
yeah I just like this places if you
really try hard you can create entire
worlds in them how cool is that we did
seem like your thing oh that's so sweet
and yours hey you never know you could
be in a world I create it right now huh
this is getting too many I better go
before something weird happens
and I sit right over there although I'm
probably gonna move soon peachie
well I sit with this odd girl cuz we're
both really quiet but reason well she's
been hanging out with someone a lot see
so they'll want to sit together of
course they're bumping you have let me
beat them in fees oh it's nothing like
that
they're just they just look happy
together so I should get them to sit at
the same table right that is so cute
skill hey my least favorite class would
you have guessed that everyone else
would have played football
well Larry can we play anything else
than football please Jesus Christ
playing playing the scales on an orc so
I just had a memory flashback in my my
brain distrust him like a hawk God plane
Fang scales an orchestral level now huh
she taught him well
Hey look at those scales
oh he's looking at her
oh my god
get that feeling when you know the
emotions gonna hit you at some point it
just had that feeling I don't like I'm
signing myself up to be vulnerable
I didn't take it it when be sorry what I
clicked on was it the watch I don't know
what are you doing there you go it was
okay
genius pants strikes a game thank you
very much you know if they was so
important that he recalls so much about
her even now what happened to her we
haven't seen any traces later on I guess
we're gonna have to find out hey have a
few guesses I don't want to know
dagnabbit
dagnabbit thank you for keeping a
Christian just the way I like
but is this the police it's a hospital
no
an airline pilot had white we're here
who are you ah wrong room sorry oh my
god the lost meme it's gonna come out of
nowhere
sorry feather storm grounded my plane
back all day and I just whoa
what oh it's a fear oh my god I just had
him yeah I was out had my god his face
kid he made it
that's not her voice
is that
honey you're vibrating the baby while
you're not supposed to vibrate the baby
sorry
you better take up I'm just gonna be
right back
what why is he going
yeah
he's not okay
the fetus what is he doing
you have one of the papers
they had nothing to say about that
seriously
you're happy though right of course I am
it's just that
don't know I was in such a rush to get
back and suddenly singing me here I
guess I just needed a moment for it to
sink in hey it's okay I feel it too you
know but well maybe it's that it's as
they say maybe we're never meant to feel
ready how could I when I feel no
different from the kid I was yesterday
but you are you are different even from
the man you were when I first met you I
don't know what changed but you're no
longer aloof you know when you're here
you're actually here
I could even even make it here when I
was born when he was born
well hey we didn't know he was so eager
to meet us early what matters is you're
here now
and we're gonna be okay I heard a lot of
a lot of families they don't connect
with their child right away I mean it's
different for mothers who's been
carrying the baby but like for father
still all the sudden just love the child
or whatever
I guess he's just shocked about it
yeah we're gonna be okay
there you go guess it was twos -
sporadic okay
what's the men memento Mentos
huh
shouldn't it be the okay I felt like I'm
shooting her anyway anyway should never
pin yes it would have been weird to
shoot the baby and it's time for genius
pants to strike again everybody what the
heck did I click on this is this day oh
okay I see it no I don't I got to do
this first and then I got into this No
yeah I got it no what are you damn it
gads peered strikes again everybody
it's very very old-school Japanese anime
the soundtrack I really like it reminds
me of I can't remember any names
I forgot I need to actually click travel
I don't know why you have to do that
this is weird how could I when I feel no
different from the kid I was yesterday
but you are different even from the man
you are when I first met you either
there's gonna be some major plot twist
or okay we are getting slowly but surely
into the center center of this puzzle I
don't what to call it
what far out but where is he did he get
drift to finish be in pain don't worry I
got this how Duke it sorry I keep
getting a text message and I just gotta
make sure it's nuts and something
important I will most likely forget
okay he's on the other side wait we
could just she look me oh all we need to
do is to get over that whoa
I don't know what you're planning but
let's try and keep it simple don't worry
it doesn't get any simpler than this oh
my god what is he doing what come on
give me a break I was ready to try it is
all right I guess it's straightforward
enough Oh with a mouse I got it max that
I can feel II Eva what this hook shot
it's Duke that would pierce the heavens
Gurren Lagann reference well then very
nice oh oh we oh it's the moon dude um
oh it's Neptune of course ensuring that
you'd and put it back in orbit right now
relax it was a copy-paste not cut paste
not to mention in part procedurally
generated now let me just turn on its
localized gravity uh-oh it's gonna spin
as isn't it no that isn't
this is Maegan insane okay Wow
what you said it was a right to use my
hook shot now let's just try the gravity
event
Hey look at that that was easy
bye-bye Neptune thanks for the lift
I left him said thanks what the heck
would just the jokes what was that
nothing let's get going at least we
didn't hook shot
Uranus everybody at least we didn't do
that huh
talk about staying up past bedtime
don't even be
it's not gonna flare rittany which is
very pain
soon are you ever gonna finish telling
me this theory there wouldn't be the
Indy paid you Fame when you were a teen
that's not much to it you know how it
goes the pirate had a broken wing and
that took care of it for a while the vet
took it in afterwards but be weird but I
tried to steal the bird back so you you
take better care of it of course not I I
know I shouldn't have didn't win because
it was my only friend I guess I just
didn't want to let it go
where would a little sappy session me I
might give you a hankerchief Frank dog
or even a cat but it bud
hey Birds I'm feeling stupid I know I
shouldn't have said anything
everyone I told that story to either
thought that or got bored to sleep King
hippity Wow fayefaye
but everyone goes into things with their
own context Indian I really tell me
about it maybe throne II feel that they
didn't care much for it
maybe the breed was something different
today than he was today or maybe you
just stick to didn't it
I just wanted them to relay he had he
how did they work it for you need every
story is meant to be turned in deep
simmer them are meant to be kept
so how did you name I I think the bird
flew off I think I lost it but it came
back to say goodbye one day you think I
don't know he kept on mixing up reality
with Dane dreaming back then I guess I
was living in my head alone too much
hey she got it hey zucchini beauties I
used to drain daydream about taking off
on a big paper plane you know we'd fly
all over the world and seeing all kinds
of things and I could just fly across
from balcony to balcony it's that way he
wanted to be a pilot
let's team you can't flame paper plane
silly no duh I mean if you really want
to fly to me why don't you go in became
a painting wait you're serious
what do you mean why not one does simply
go tomorrow just go and become a pilot
where do you think we because how when
place to go from here three three it
doesn't hurt you find when an egg
that's if only it could be that simple
if you could if you took let it be me me
King I think you could I know
Hey
I'm gonna look for an airport tomorrow
so straight
but we have two more Mentos must be
inside he has a pacman post Wow seemed
like he ran into a poster sale our
puberty poster of a horror movie
hmm do you think he had it a name
probably just a poser
the balcony room like this its parents
are confident in his sleep oculus nice
oh I see it my bed poster of a tropical
island surrounded by a lagoon and
Barrier Reef hmm that exam it is it's
the same place as the painting hanging
above his bed in his cell early days
he's also keeping this exact same
picture in the Attic even now for a
teenager he sure had some old-fashioned
tapes and posters of what is cement oh
here here maybe here maybe he's dead
much Demento we didn't really check
everywhere outside so this must be a
paper plane
No we got all the Mentos
maybe the book I mean if you really want
to fly so bad
Fay said why don't you go and become a
pilot so they screen book from the shelf
it's just a journal seems legit Wow boo
ping it's time for everyone's favorite
genius pills gonna solve this puzzle
like no other
all right so we need the book right okay
all right okay and it's literally
impossible to get it there I see already
what I have to do
boom
Bing thumb genius hilts strikes again
sorry
activate the memo I'm really really
enjoying the game right now it took a
while to get into but at this point it's
just I mean I'm into it I don't know
what say wow so much for the cliffhanger
and well so much for the gif hangar of
whether he became a pilot a well we
already knew more likely thing
no captain earns Oakland Center cactus
one-three-five cruising flight level 3 9
and 0
ATC cactus 1 3 5 Oakland Center
altimeters selling 300 7cm altimeter 300
a 7 cactus 1 3 5 out see greenhorn you
got to play with the rolls and 9 use
them proper Ranger words every single
thing even when you're not on radio at
home to your bath but the chief
instructor said with this award-winning
mustache don't you think I'll be going
easy on you just cause this is your
first flight we'll look at my face on
Twitter there's only two things I ever
want to hear from you there yes captain
and landing gear down that's funny sir
no you don't sir yes captain
so IDing gear down
son-of-a-gun they send me older brother
brother once this can't be serious
well you know how memory is getting
saturated symptoms i hope captain earns
my man i had one request do not send me
a guard and what are they there they
send me a girl he still kept he's still
keeping journals in this thing it just
comes it's just some sort of preflight
checklist glued on here Sharleen well
how was your first day
it's captain earns always like that I
barely did a thing but sit there yeah
you should probably get used to that for
a while
forget about him though you got any
plans for tonight for the name the other
flight attendants and I were thinking of
taking you at for some drinks to
celebrate oh oh tell them thanks but I
better head straight back home my wife's
just about halfway into her first
trimester I'm always for long enough um
I'm away long way in it I'm away for
long enough as it is
Wow debbye Congrats got a name picked
yet yeah we're thinking a sure route
there it is
cacao and cacao
it's time for everyone's favorite mammy
paid debit debit how does this work okay
oh I got a do-more Hey look at that
excuse me genius Pierce strikes again
thank you very much
oh yeah we got it I keep forgetting I
keep forgetting I just gotta click on it
silly me
damn feels like we're not moving much in
time here what the hell maybe something
happened really here came eh Oh which
reminds me why when I was a kid we went
to a newspaper plays and there was a
photographer there and I was really into
photography at the time because my mom
mom was as well and I asked him like how
do I become a photographer
and I remember his his reply was so
sarcastic and stupid and they made me
feel really dumb for even asking
I really turned me off from like even
wanting it and I think it's when you're
so young yeah be careful what you say I
don't know this matter I ended up okay
anyway excuse me are you an airline
pilot it's a small Muni simple airport
kid you won't find any airlines here I'm
a charter pilot you look into a charter
charter a plane I'm looking to learn to
fly can you teach me
looking for an early start huh sounds
like you want to talk to the flight
school instead make a turn up ahead and
follow the hall they'll deal with with
you at this patch see attach III III
berry ah gimme give me my fix East
everything why did I ever learn no wow
what a great painting that looks great
what in the world is that just leaving
thinking for the keys maybe the head
should have been smaller for
aerodynamics sake okay it's good extra
propulsion coming out of it
mmm great but what's gonna happen next
with Barry is what I want to know
where's Barry's place in this story
their place where they disappeared see
you mean where they take off Cathy we do
order flight training and you do meet
the requirements but it's costly is
there any other way at all well that's
not up for me to say
why don't you check with the owner he's
on a break right now and I'll let him
know you're coming that the owner of the
entire Airport
yep it's his family own Airport his
office at the other side of the hop what
what does that mean it means anything
baby dick in your students probably
Murphy mafia but mafia I'm behind you
you know yeah just like the kid let's
get me what nanny
city kids
indeed
this does feel like The Godfather
doesn't it you've gotta be kidding me
sure so you are the kid they told me
about look sir
I don't want any trouble of course you
don't want son there there's there's a
word out on the street that you want to
become a pilot yes sir
but you have no experience no sir no
background no and you have no money
I don't sir
yet you come here on the day of my own
daughter's final exam to request my
hospitality to make use of my facility
without an offer do you disrespect me
and my family's airport tell him you get
three rooms I mean you can hear bad at
the AAP I got reasonably strong arms ah
are you saying you're up for work yes
you are
yeah I am hmm interesting proposal it's
true there have been a few positions
opening up recently perhaps we could use
a hand very well your offer is one I
won't refuse another amaretto sour
Ricardo and hold the amaretto is that is
that the like orange drink they was
originally kid
you work for me now and with the
earnings you shall pay for your training
one flight at a time
quick Thank You mr. Peck thank you for
your kindness sir see wait a minute all
that happen all that's happening since I
applied for a job [ __ ] you practically
fear to break me
so I'm assuming exaggeration of memories
it's just like racists to Italians I
can't tell Oh triggered is that a
microaggression Italians isn't a race
Neil but he does seem to have a tendency
forgetting creative with his memories
hey maybe that's just what he gets for
watching the movie when he's a anyhow
let's see if the Diane has anything for
us all right he's a memento
can we walk around yeah uh-huh
this time a data there it is it's time
for everyone's favorite for beauty pie
this looks trickier
I can't move and I can't
gotta get three in a row somehow
okay
this should do the trick now of course I
shoot okay let's do it this way
yeah yeah I did it and it's the orange
drink that everyone drinks in Italy I
don't know why it's so weird never had
one see them everywhere at bars
all right what are we now in Italy ooh
such cheerful music finally subtropical
air over in the middle of shoes there
you go sir your amaretto ser hold the
amaretto things just the way I like it
and for you lady your amaretti sir hold
this air why thank you I didn't know you
guys make this are you gonna be able to
handle all that lemon juice
it's an old favorite we're actually here
you wanted to visit for a long time now
haven't you
is it everything you dreamed it would be
well when you got expectations but yes
it's still beautiful
how about you though hmm you know
spending half our savings on a delayed
honeymoon and all that hey now it's not
the time to think you like that
well bands back up I got quite a few
gigs waiting when we get that not to
mention your new job
mr. airline pilot don't jinx it I might
still be a while until I start with the
company they might still besides the pay
is not gonna be good for a while hey as
long as you get to wear the cool shades
I talked with Maria last week we got the
flexible hour arranged so we're ready
huh yeah but as ready as we're gonna be
you know this might be the last trip
like this will happen a long time yeah
well make the little bastard pay for all
the vacation we missed one day in the
meantime all the more reason to enjoy
the rest of it here's to the rest of it
yeah oh my god uh-huh
smooth banner
okay I'm so glad I kept playing this
game
it is so enjoyable to play the
atmosphere and and and the pacing of the
story it's so good I'm really really
happy
I don't know you can just click the gun
but I'm gonna end this episode here
thank you guys for watching and
supporting in this let's play even
though getting a lot of you but it's a
bonus video saying anyway stay awesome
press